bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fatti j
oggi siamo tornati su over glock che non
lo facciamo da secoli ragazza venuta
voglia pazzesca di giocarlo perché da
tipo anni che non lo faccio per chi non
lo conoscesse ragazzino ma la vedo
difficile perché un gioco troppo troppo
troppo famosissimo ovviamente ci sono
sti conigli che si rincorrono per
incrociarsi è una nuova bellissimo sole
e cornici giocare ed è una carneficina
pazzesca ho già ammazzato sto tizio
senza volerlo è poi da cosa [ __ ] e
questa assaggio al mio culo zio lo ha
mancato di te poi non so come ho fatto a
mi sono rimesso in piedi ma va bene così
duri princi reattivo i comandi per
chiamare da secoli ecco nicchia che
botto parato eccolo eccolo eco o mio dio
amica se ce la faccio cosa ho preso
basta non voglio il comando del mondo
adesso io ho fatto un culo pazzesco
tanta roba
fatemi capire un attimo come riprendere
intanto c'è sangue sono molto mi ha
mancato ecco perfetta adesso te lo
prendi tritone madonna che cartella me
dava uguali mia madre quando tornava
prendevo due fatti avanti tu prima che
ecco soft combattere albi che devono
capire un attimo non mi ricordi come
come si scriva che prima lo stimato ecco
asi madonna che mostra l'on
a furia di fare il figo ma ho fatto un
culo così ma non fa niente di merda
madonna no vabbè ma è impossibile
salutati fortissimi provincia l'ho mai
preso
eccolo tecnico calci in faccia ma
anch'io ho tanto quello che succede se
per il nostro tasto
perché c'è un tizio che urla che cazzo
succede
enrico bastardi è niente l'ice ha già la
mia spada strano savoia stasera serviamo
coniglio fatto è un attimo con la lancia
prima di tornare giusto per capire come
funziona perché non mi ricordo più
eccolo ecco quello che quella è morto a
caldo cosa ho detto ho detto fuori
stronzo che io ti dico ascoltami se non
mi ascolti che la prendi diritto nel
collo
io lo amo rallenti sto gioco che
cacciava bombe questo ecco a parte la
testata mia sul muro ho fatto una cosa
epica 1 gradisce del coniglio non
chiedono chiesto a te stronzo ragazzi
come fa schivare i colpi mentre trascina
un coniglio che non è possibile perché
va indietro cioè hai paura di stop a io
li sto trascinando un coniglio addosso
lunge e tre già va bene mai paura che te
lo lanci zio perché sei indietreggiando
xhafa potessi lanciare ecco la mossa del
coniglio ragazzi me l'ero dimenticate
bellissime come si muove come cazzo
incazzatissimo proprio perdonatemi
ragazzi ma doveva l'ascolta mitigato mi
fai sul culo ok ok non sei a noi mi
alleato mi trovo lo pestarono a sangue
meno male di capirmi in attimo se io ti
se io ti guardo così e ti faccio così
deve indietreggiare è già un po morto
forse parate di questa come ho fatta
mancare lo prete non lo prendi ente
inutile che fai gesù spiega mi sono
ricordato una roba epica che se riesco a
farle bellizio veloce ecco perfetto ore
15 85 ed esattore di sarah la breda non
si è ancora accorta di noi e ce la
passiamo fa in azione mossa di
sculettamento tattico
[Musica]
11 87 la preda non sia ancora corta lino
e quindi stiamo per passare all'attacco
perfetto cazzo ritirata siamo inseguiti
dalla pretesto per sto sto camminando in
modo sexy no no no no kat omise ridotto
il cuore è prezzo di me mi dai una mano
per favore che lui lido bastardo adesso
sono armato ed è più cattivo di prima
gliela lanci per favore non mi dico
ragazzi amico nomi si lancia la spada
bellissimo si no cazzo la mia è ma sei
un pezzente di merda ragazzi e ragazze
come lo disarmo adesso a cascata
calmiamoci io ho sbagliato tasto quindi
volevo soltanto puntarti i capelli o
detto calmo brutto per center
ok ok se vinco questa giro nudo per casa
giuro non è possibile
ecco infatti meno male che ho perso
perché avrei dovuto girare nudo ma
eccolo laggiù ci siano terminati ma chi
è
non manca è male ma [ __ ] è
possibile che io sono quello con le armi
e lui è quello che vince sempre ok
ragazzi il piano b piano vi andiamo in
casa che meglio loggia ecco qua non ci
arriva ma non ci arriva
cazzo si madonna sono superman
se lo fa non c'è una scala vero ditemi
che non c'è una scala non c'è una scala
che è botta di culo adesso ragazzi
mentre lui cerca una scala che non c'è
voglio vedere senza mettermi in altra
arma ecco madonna cos'è sta roba c'è una
scala apre yacht ansa serie a la scala e
meno male
vabbè di questo zio affanculo niente non
si fa lui non si fa niente madonna che
mosè pica che morse etica non sa epica
un cazzo faccia a beccarlo tipo come la
come fa a prenderla lui ma seriamente ma
vaffan
no vabbè ma non è possibile ragazzi
allora figlio di pupa torna cos'è con un
martello ragazzi ho trovato ho vinto
basta con questo fottutamente v dove
ragazzi stavolta ho vinto
stavolta ho vinto ma perché
sono lui ragazzi può pararsi e
riprendere il martello dopo che si è
parato bellissimo sul genio ha vinto
tutto adesso lo presti ma ma usa lo sto
martello di me
ok c'è il martello e tiri calci ma se ed
efficiente con questo tramonto
ti darò il colpo di grazia non ce la
faccio
ce la faccio ha combattutto che
finalmente che va dall in casa vedere se
viziato avanti un altro round 1 ragazzi
due punti per vincere stavolta c'è lo
devo fare per forza
solo che è infatti i nemici hanno le
spade io non un cazzo da fermi un attimo
fermi deve uscire sto pagando ho paura
che qualcuno mi arrivi addosso
sì l'ho preso preso che calmi calmi da
chi è che roba non lo so neanche chi da
che devo uccidere occhiali ci siamo 1 a
0 devo scegliere un'altra volta amica
dopo una lancia nello stomaco ancora in
piedi studi come cazzo fare lo stronzo è
lo so che vinco facile zio però anche
prima più stronzo di merda [ __ ]
[ __ ] ok sai parare i colpi te lo
concedo sai continuamente parare i colpi
te lo concedo ma quest'ultimo no e
allora sei stronzo
ho vinto ho vinto non hanno vinto ha
detto io prendo la lancia la lancia al
volo compreso il gol che ho fatto peggio
di katniss come adesso voi mi spiegate
come la parata non è possibile
piano piano c'è l'ho preso
se ho vinto ho vinto scorsi ho sfruttato
con fatto una vita voglio rivedermi il
replay toe dopo nel video quando
riusciranno lo riguardano 20 volte mi
hanno tirato quattro lanciate sullo
stomaco sono vivo questo perché mangio
al mcdonald questo no questo no il
martello beccati il martello ma come fai
a respingere un martello
adesso voi vi spiegate scientificamente
come possibile questa cosa come fossi
come come fa ci siamo
io che volevo fare una cosa frega niente
non serve posso prendere ma come si fa
prendere l'arma gli altri quindi si
possono fermare tipo si sono come si
riservano fermi ecco adesso l'ho presa
adesso se nota che ci arrivo dai che ci
arrivo
se il serio veramente sono morto così la
mia wright bastardo si sono fatta
ragazzi ce lo fa gusto pezzo di merda
cazzo sono fruivano stavo scattare zio
ma non sai stare uno scherzo ma ciò è
fatta di nuovo su cup non stava
scherzando va qualcuno me ne vado
libertà sono morto se combatti cosa
combat mi spieghi sto martello dove
l'hai preso cosa fai ci schiacci le noci
stronzo cosa ci fai con sto martello
stai ascoltando musica zio ascolterei
molto volentieri con te ma ti va se ti
do sto martello dato un pugno non volevo
presente mai [ __ ] però aspetta che se
c'è un'arma tipo questa l'ho presa
adesso vuoi vedere che me lo para son
convinto sapevo ci avrei scommesso
qualsiasi cosa ascoltami zio non puoi ma
porca di quella punta come no no non lo
si casca tutto proprio tutto e cia il
clan sfida queste bellissime sono un
loop ho capito ma c'è qualcuno da
uccidere oppure tutta così e khatami zio
mi hai visto
ma sai che non me ne frega proprio un
cazzo addirittura st musica per un tizio
così minuscolo un hub affanculo siccome
ragazzi ancora non c'è chi nato nessuno
voglio provare ad andare là sopra e
vedere se esco lanciargli una lancia
lanciargli una lancia non si può sentire
sbatto è se va beh ho sbattuto contro un
albero e sono morto che è certo ma come
prassi come è possibile straparlando
riuscire ucciderlo sì l'ho preso non per
questa è una cosa che lo dica gli ho
dato una banda ai ragazzi poi
sull'ultima prova a vedere se riesco a
prendere qualcosa ha trovato la lancia
però capitola solo lei presa stronzo
madonna
[Musica]
che botta assurda di cui come lo come
l'ho preso come è stata la bassa ma dopo
questo ho vinto tutto
i ragazzi concluso qui perché mi vengono
rigiocarci da un botto quindi ho colto
l'occasione comunque ragazzi spero che
il video vi sia più sotto il video è
piaciuto come al solito ha lasciato un
commento mi piace anche a profili
facebook e come non di video trovate una
descrizione se vorresti di stile temi ci
mettiamo un prossimo video delle ragazze
[Musica]